The thing I wanted to talk about today, um...
One of the things
is a.. the coolness that is public-private key cryptography
The basic idea of how it works
I think is uh...
is just cool and such clever idea that I want to explain it
So everyone is familiar with the basic idea of crypto, where
you umm
You have a secret key
You used that to
encode some information which converts it from a readable format to
garr
garbage effectively
ah.. it looks like a random noise
You then transfer it to somebody else
and they then able to decrypt it and get the message out
and anyone who is listening here on your communication
um...
isn't able to find out anything about the information that you are communicating
the way
you intuitively think about, especially if you
doing these simple codes, something like caesar cypher that you might do
when you are a kid
there's one
there's one secret that you both have, right, this...this is a symmetric system
so you have got
your message saying HELLO
and then you do some process to it
to convert it
using a key
that some secret piece of information
which then converts this into nonsense
and then you send this
to the other person
and they decrypt it
with the process that kind of same process in reverse
using the same key
and then again HELLO
backout at the other end
and that's nice and simple it works
um... and it was once
sort of only way people did this
but it has a problem which is
you both need to know what this key is
so if it is you and me. And we want to communicate with one another privately
we have to agree on  a key
that's nobody else gonna guess
and we have to share it with one anther
um
so  we might meet in the park in secret and exchange envelopes
or whatever
this is the kind of things spy used to do, right
and the problem with that is
first its very inconvinient
second, you sometimes can't do it, might be physically separated
or we want to do something over internet
and we never met
the problem is that how do I send this key to you
without just sending the key in the clear, as  it were unencrypted
inorder for us to share the key safely
we need a secure encrypted connection
but we can't establish a secure encrypted connection without a key
there's a way of solving this problem
which is asymmetric encryption
um...where what you do is generate two keys
key a
and key b
let's just call then and i m drawing a line
asymmetric system you have two keys
and then basically it's same as before
you have got your message
says hello
you encrypt it with key a
to say
whatever it was that I decided it was
and then back out you get HELLO again
and decryption in this case uses key b
you can't guess one key from other
but they are linked in such a way that
anything you encrypt with key a can only be decrypted with key b
and anything you encrypt with key b can only be decrypted with key a
so there's two
and what you do is
you generate a pair of these keys, which is called key pair
and
you just pick one of them
and say
this is my public key
right and your public key
is public
you publish it everywhere
you put it
you put it at the end of emails
your forum posts
you...you upload it to keyserver
just specialized serve system designed for
storing, securely storing people public keys
basic idea is it's everywhere out
there in the world with your name on it
the private key
is the other key of this pair
that one you keep absolutely secret
you can do some cool things with this once you have system setup
i have a key pair
you have a key pair
we both have one another public key
so now if you want to send me a message
i don't have to share anything with you
you just know my public key
encrypt something with my public key
send it to me
you know i can decrypt it
because i have my private key
and then there's another thing you can do with this
which is
if i encrypt something with my private key
and then publish it
now on the surface you may think what is the point
of encrypting it
with your private key
because your public key is out there and anything can decrypt it
so why bother encrypting
but
the fact that it can be decrypted with your public key
means it must have been encrypted with your private key
which it must have been you who made the message
because only you have your private key
cryptographically you can be certain
that it's an authentic message really from that person
so the best thing is that when I do both
where i encrypt something from my private key
and then your public key
and then send it to you
and if we communicate like this
i know that no body else gonna read the message
you know that no body else can read the message
you know that message is come from me, not an impostor
you also know that the message hasn't been modified
because any modification to the message also require the keys
that's a great secure system and
we didn't have to meet up in the park
in a secret way
and exchange any information or anything
we never have met
i need to make clear here that I have oversimplified in various ways
people who understands cryptography will be quiet
upset
probably
by now
but guys this is
this is why people don't use crypto
because we make it to complicated
core concept is simple
and basic stuff isn't it difficult to use
and everyone should
when you put envelope in the post
you kind of assume
you lick the things to seal it
and if it's been open
people will know it's been open
and there is laws about this
and we have to know these stuffs
when you communicate in the clear
you know anyone and his dog can know exactly what you're sending to everyone
and there's no reason to allow that